hey guys pete here today i'm gonna break
down
episodes one and two of fargo season
four there were a lot of characters
introduced in this fourth installment of
the anthology series
a lot we go way back in time to the
1950s
and leave minnesota behind to travel
south to kansas city missouri there's a
lot going on in the first two episodes
but the backdrop of the story seems to
be the tensions between
two rival gangs the canon limited and
the fada family when you put their two
names together it sounds like
cannon fodder and that probably didn't
happen by accident
before i recap what happened this is
your spoiler warning
if you haven't watched the first two
episodes of fargo season 4 yet this
video won't be for you
episode 1 is titled welcome to the
alternate economy and it starts out with
a school report
delivered by ethel ryder pearl smutny in
20
minutes we get a history lesson about
organized crime in kansas city
and how power shifted over the 50 years
since the moskovitz
syndicate a gang of jewish immigrants
set up shop at the turn of the century
from there the irish milligan concern
took over
until the italian fada family moved in
ethel ryda tells us here's the thing
about america
the minute you're relaxed and fat enough
somebody hungrier is gonna come along
looking for a piece of your pie and we
see that even though the ruling families
have a tradition of trading sons to be
raised by their rivals in an attempt to
keep the peace
it never really worked the most
interesting story
folded into the conflict here is that of
rabbi milligan
the youngest in the irish family he was
sent to live with the moskowitz's
instead of keeping the peace he helped
his family get into the compound
and take it by violent mean years later
when the italians arrived to make the
same alliance with the irish who are now
in charge
rabbi gets traded again this time he
decides to change
sides and gives his adopted fada family
the advantage
they then end up on top of the
underworld where they remain
until we enter the present day of season
4.
ethel ryder describes it like this
whoever was last
off the boat finding the doors of honest
capital closed
rolled up their sleeves and got to work
getting rich the old-fashioned way
different groups of outsiders or those
that are considered the other
fighting over the scraps of whatever
power they could get knocking each other
down all the way
the 16 year old who seems to be our
sensible character in the middle of
things
also lays out what sounds like the big
question the season
is concerned with if america is a nation
of immigrants
then how does one become american at the
end of her report we see loy cannon
head of the cannon limited enter into an
alliance with donatella
fada head of the fodder family loy comes
off as cool and calculated
in a meeting with a local bank where he
pitches his new idea for a credit card
we see that he has big ideas
good ideas destined to fall on deaf ears
based on his being from the wrong race
and class
he still has enough power that the
italians can't overlook him though and
so
in following with the tradition a new
sun exchange is agreed upon
his son satchel will be raised by the
photos and he takes in
zero in true fargo fashion
a somewhat random event turns things
upside down
donatello gets hit in the neck with a
stray pellet from some
kids who are playing with a bb gun his
family rushes him to the nearest
hospital where the man
in charge dr harvard turns him away for
being italian
and therefore not a respectable american
at the public hospital he
appears to be on the road to recovery
until his son josto
has a conversation with the quirky nurse
who he hit
up for some drugs to pick him up after a
stressful day
after their conversation the nurse
orienta mayflower
takes it on herself to give donatello a
lethal dose of something
orienta establishes herself as a wild
card and brings with her the obligatory
minnesota accent
in other scenes we see that both her
drug use
and her propensity to euthanize her
patients are well established parts of
her character
she lives across the street from smutny
funeral home where she crosses paths
with etherida for as much as we've seen
her
orienta's motivations are pretty much a
mystery
it's possible she's just a psychopathic
nurse that likes to kill her patients
but i'm guessing there's more to her
story
her taking out donatello leaves josto in
charge
but we see his bug-eyed brother return
from italy to complicate things
further this could set up a power
struggle inside the family but in their
moment of weakness
the canons make a move which diverts
their attention
before his death loy tried to get
control of a slaughterhouse
in his neighborhood from donatello he
said no
but the canon limited decided to act as
if he said yes
they're number two in charge dr senator
takes over the business
and then gaetano fada sweeps in to take
it back
while this is going on josto has his
hands full trying to get his murderous
revenge on dr
harvard his guys attempt to drive by
that fails when harvard survives
that brings another new character
detective otis weff
into the picture he appears to have ocd
and we learn that he's on the fought a
payroll which means he's going to have
to come up with someone to frame
to keep josto's name out of it they
didn't hit their main target
but some people died including a
well-to-do
donor so someone's gonna have to pay the
price
a couple of other characters enter the
picture after escaping from
prison etherida's aunt zelmer roulette
and her accomplice swanny cap who tells
the story about attending white schools
where they were mostly concerned with
trying to rape the native out of her
these two end up hiding out at the
funeral home they said they came because
they heard the family were in over their
heads with a couple of leg breakers
the smutneys are in debt to the cannons
and from what we can tell they don't
have a plan to get on the right side of
things yet
swanny mentions bank robbery as a
possible solution
but by episodes n their freedom appears
to be in question
as us marshals show up on the doorstep
that's only part of the cliffhanger
though
before they arrive we see oreda drop off
a pie that's
loaded with syrup of ipecac on their
porch
this is after she offered ethorida a job
cleaning her apartment
and said that she wanted to make her one
of her special projects
how that translates to a vomit-inducing
pie delivery is yet to be
seen but i feel like these two etherida
and orienta
are the two most interesting characters
in season four
they have a healthy amount of quirk and
there's potential for them to shine
while navigating through some difficult
circumstances
and situations that's kind of what makes
fargo work for me
and these two inhabit the spaces on the
opposite end of the spectrum
the younger brings to mind a molly
salverson
or gloria burgle and the older might be
up the same alley as
someone like lauren malvo or bm varga
things are changed up nicely in that
etherida isn't a cop
and that orienta may be less predictable
in what drives her than the other two
villains i mentioned
it's easy to see that we're supposed to
like etherida for her calm demeanor her
smarts and her relative purity compared
to those around her
and even though orienta is clearly
chaotic
we can also put together that she's
quick on her feet and able to get what
she wants
she got caught trying to kill one of her
patients and managed to secure
two months severance with a letter of
recommendation from her boss
as he was firing her so she's out there
but she isn't completely out of control
in a world where respect is currency
most of the characters go
out of their way not to give it there's
a lot of punching down
or punching sideways at the very least
the fada brothers are almost cartoonish
in most of their interactions
there's some humor there but it could
all get old
josto has plans to increase his power
through a political marriage
but otherwise seems like your typical
fail son
gaetano presents as aggressive and
unstable
but that could prove valuable in their
family business
even though the sun exchange seems like
a big part of the setup the current kids
caught up in it
right now haven't really been focused on
they're young
and we don't really see much except for
them listening to the older people
around them
the fact that rabbi milligan is in
charge of watching satchel cannon seems
important i think based on his role in
the history of things there's probably
more to rabbi's story
and he might be the connection to the
other seasons of fargo as we know
they're all connected and we did meet a
milligan
in season 2 who happens to be black
chris rock's role is pretty restrained
at this point he's doing a fine job of
keeping us cool
and delivering a big line now and again
a couple that stood out in these
episodes were him telling donatello
you think part of being american is
standing on my neck
and his comment about the world being
dog eat dog he says that's how dogs work
men are more complicated so he's
delivered when he has a chance
i also like his right hand man doctor
senator
he seems like a pretty strong character
and he's delivered some good lines as
well
i thought the rats hanging up at the
slaughterhouse to scare the others away
was a funny bit as was dr senator's
response to it
saying that he might be overestimating
the brain power of his
foe there's quite a few coen brothers
references
a few that stood out right away to me
were
obviously the gang land angle that
brings miller's crossing to mind
i doubt many people missed the cattle
gun in action at the slaughterhouse
but obviously that featured heavily in
no country for old men
in episode two we see it being used for
its actual
purpose the prison break made me think
of raising arizona
of course there was a lot less mud but
it definitely had the same kind of feel
as was the opening narration which had a
similar feel as well
i haven't had a chance to go back and
really look but i'm sure there's plenty
more that i missed at this point
as i mentioned there are a ton of
characters it was almost a little bit
overwhelming and it made it so that none
of them really were driving the story
it'll be interesting to see where they
go i mean obviously we're gonna have a
clash
between the two families but beyond that
we'll just have to wait and see because
there's a lot going on
i'm interested to hear what you think so
let me know in the comments
who do you think's gonna eat the pie
what's gonna happen when they do
do you think the fadas can keep gaitano
on the leash or is there gonna be
a power struggle inside the family
what's gonna happen with the fugitives
when the marshals knock on the front
door
and what do you think that orienta's
backstory is and her motivation will be
going forward as the season progresses
with that i'm going to leave it there
let me know what you think please like
this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon